every morning and every night
and then every morning
that's ritual if i don't take them i get
really poorly these are just some of the
drugs that keep katie alive sorry
obviously i've been on them for life she
has brittle asthma and suffers from
non-epileptic seizures but even with
these drugs sometimes katie needs urgent
medical attention
it happened last month
i was
very very
short of breath
very white clammy
and it was it was terrifying
why terrified
i'm terrified of
any time that
i will collapse because
i'm not getting enough oxygen in or
the medication that i can do at home is
not going to work
katie says her health deteriorated after
waiting an hour for an ambulance
and not knowing how long one would take
she called her dad mark who lives 15
miles away
there was ambulances parked on the side
of the road as you come around
with patients and
with patients in
and police fans of patients that
obviously dearly needed an ambulance but
the police had to escort them to the
hospital
once triaged katie says she had to wait
for nearly eight hours on a trolley in
an emergency department bay because
there were no beds i asked them
how long is it going to be that i wait
in a e
and
he was very truthful with me he said
look
i don't know
it'll be until early late hours of the
morning if we could get you a bed
up on another ward there is no beds
there is no space
hospital trusts and ambulance services
up and down the country are facing
pressure like never before may was the
second busiest month on record
for a d
the great western hospitals nhs
foundation trust apologized to katie for
her long wait to be treated and said
that can be the case when they're busy
as they treat patients in order of
clinical urgency
katie's partner jamie worries patients
are being put at risk i know we're still
in the pandemic
and it has been two years and everyone's
trying to
live life as normal as they can
but the nhs is struggling and
it is worrying because
people are going to lose lives because
of it
katie and her family do not blame health
staff but they are worried that if
something isn't done soon to ease nhs
pressure
then patients will die
ashish josh is sky news in swindon